today I'm gonna show everyone a trick
that can check your with meticulous no
this I think every adult should know
this and I don't think everyone does
know it it's called casting out nines
it's a method to check your arithmetic
it's what they used in the old days
before calculators and let's say we're
doing something like 2039 plus 172 plus
whatever 1218 plus 3091 let's see we're
doing something like that okay
this add these up I'm just gonna add the
up in the traditional way I'm not doing
anything clever here so you add up
column by column okay I reckon it's 6520
but what if I've done it wrong or if
I've made a mistake so here's a check
that you can do so what we're going to
do we're going to reduce each of these
numbers to a single digits and the way
we do that is we're going to add up the
digits in each number so 2 plus 3 is 5
plus 9 is 14 I want to reduce it to a
single digit so I'm just going to do it
again now I'm going to take the 14 1
plus 4 hope you're happy with that I'm
going to do that with each number one
plus seven plus two I reckon that's 10
let's switch to reduce that down so 1
plus 0 is a 1 this is what I get
so I get this 5 1 3 & 4 now I'm going to
perform the same calculation using these
numbers so I'm just adding them here it
says add them together side them
together okay five plus one it's a six
plus a 3 is a nine plus four it's a 13
actually I'm going to reduce that down
if you don't mind to a single digit 4
but now if you do the same thing with
your answer ok 6520 add this up is a 13
which gives me a final digit there of 4
and these are the same and they should
be now if they're not the same that's
how you know your calculation has gone
wrong so this is a way to check your
calculations without having to do the
calculation all over again
now
that was a bit laborious the way I did
it there I can actually show you just a
quick way to do it this pick a number
they let's say 43 4 plus 3 equals 7 so 7
would be the final answer it's called a
digital root but now I'm gonna add 9 to
43 gives me 50 to do the same thing with
52 it's going to be 5 plus 2 that's also
7 and that's true when you add 9 it
doesn't change the digital root so if
you look at this original calculation I
did up here actually can get rid of
nines so this fall out to start 2039
well this 9 has no effect and just get
rid of it I don't have to consider it
but in the same way this 9 here which
represents 90 has no effect that's just
like adding 9 over and over again I can
get rid of it or in fact I can get rid
of this 18th that's like adding 9 twice
that has no effect on the digital root
same for this 7 or to any combination
that makes 9 can be got rid of and then
you see so much easier now so what I've
got now is a 5 a 1 a 3 and a 4 and it's
very easy to do and then you can perform
the calculation again same thing with
this lot here look the 5 and the 4
cancel out one on three left over miksa
4 very easy to do this arithmetic it
also works for multiplication let's try
a multiplication just to see
let's do five hundred and three times
I'll do something easy I'm not trying to
show off with how good I am at
arithmetic so if times 50 what I would
do if I saw that is times it by 10 first
of all so five oh three oh times it by
five which is two five one five and then
add that up
so what I got there seven five four five
I reckon that's the answer but let's
check let's do the digital roots of each
value thousand eight that's a 6 1 plus 5
that makes a 6 and we're going to
multiply now we do the same calculation
using the digital roots 8 times 6 4
4848 will eventually end up being a
three an ass check that this is also
three if it's not I've done it wrong
let's see okay five plus four I can't
even get rid of that okay seven plus
five is a twelve add them together
hooray I'm happy that ends with a three
as well this is what people used to do
before calculators if you were a
scientist or if you are an accountant
and you needed to check your figures
very important to check your figures
this is the sort of test that you could
do so if you're wrong you'll be wrong by
some multiple of nine because if you add
nine it doesn't change the digital route
so maybe you're nine off or 90 off
that's possible true but this is a check
to see if you're right
now you might be thinking why does this
work and if you're thinking that well
done you're thinking like a
mathematician yeah why does this work
that's a good question to ask so and we
saw before adding 9 didn't change the
digital route adding 9 had no effect
it's kind of like if it was Monday and I
add seven days it's Monday again isn't
it
or if it was Monday and I add 17 days
well you'd go through 14 that'll get you
back to Monday then you would have three
more days left that'll take you to
Thursday so it's kind of the same idea
any nines in this case have no effect
and then anything left is what you have
after a multiple of nine what that means
is any number can be written as a
multiple of nine plus their digital root
so you pick a number and you can write
it as some multiple of nine plus a
here's the digital root now what happens
when I add it to another number if I add
that to another number it can be written
as a multiple of 9 plus the digital root
let's say it's be here what happens when
I do that we're going to end up with a
multiple of nine it's actually nine
times n plus M
plus these two will get added together
that B a plus B so adding these two
numbers together has the effect of being
a multiple of nine plus the sum of their
digital roots and that's why this works
you do our calculations with the
original numbers will transfer to the
same calculation with their digital
roots with multiplication you'll see we
had those two numbers as say nine n plus
a multiplied by 9 m plus V then you're
going to get a multiple of nine which is
can be nine times something not very
pretty so multiplying two numbers has
the effect of being a multiple of nine
plus the product of their digital roots
and of course multiple of nines can be
ignored they just disappear these this
would be a nine and this would then be
divided by one plus five is a six that
doesn't equal three does it that makes
no sense
we have much further to go in our race
for space so we're gonna leave Sputnik
behind for those who don't know by the
way Sputnik was the first settle I ever
to orbit the earth it wasn't launched by
the Russians we probably should have
mentioned that October the 4th 1957 yes
man knows